and what i want you to work on
is the equal and opposite energy that
comes from hitting someone
if that energy leaks out my body i will
not have mass displacement of my strife
and we need mass displacement okay
so yes body alignment
yes dropping the chi
yes fist formation yes skeletal
alignment
but it's more what do i do with that
energy coming back which is why you have
a spring in your monkey water
i want to feel that force come in me hit
the ground
and when i receive the force
everything's got to be relaxed
so i'm not good i don't want to tense
and this is just a little test of it so
again i'm not trying to kill him
so i'm not working on punching him hard
but i'm now looking for the displacement
okay i'm not pushing him
it's it's still a ballistic
[Music]
but it's got that displacing potential
so you don't push
you don't have to punch them hard you're
just
okay let's go okay so uh
we if he if he's grabbed we have this
cochlear training drill right so
here is a kind of uh fixated
movement uh generated force so he
he's pushing and and that force is going
down to the ground path on the back foot
that's what's happening here so when you
hit his body
it has uh weight and matter
and it's an energy that i have to
override um and so there's going to be
some return energy some equal and
opposite energy bond
to me but that force that comes back
i ground this same thing
that force is coming towards me i ground
so
he's pushing really really hard come on
dude knock me down
knock me down that that's what i'm doing
it's just really fast okay i don't it's
not fixated movement it's ballistic
movement
okay so that that's what i'm doing so
i don't want you because right now
you're somebody you're
leaning and it's while once you move you
kind of stumble
that's that's not what we're doing okay
so we're gonna we'll take away
my base and i will have
same energies here just like he's
pushing
he's pushing there's energy there and i
ground i ground me
okay i'm grounded so he's pushing really
hard really hard really hard really hard
really hard really hard really hard i'm
grounding
on that foot so when i come back in his
mass that equal opposite energy comes
back it growls
and it will displace it
okay so i don't you have less
urgency or feeling that you could lean
you're just here
okay let's go so um
when our when our strikes are surface
level
um there's a couple of things the guy is
going to be standing where that is and a
lot of people that do striking arts
they're kind of doing more like a pain
compliance technique
and meaning like oh that's gonna hurt
him so bad that
he's gonna you know hesitate or falter
right and it's quite common in aikido
which they don't they don't do striking
for real
and so a temmie has some sort of pseudo
psychological warfare going on
do you see that so oh you'll hit him and
he
goes like oh oh my mind goes here i
ca i don't know what to do you know and
then then you can throw the guy
you know um
but you should have sound tactics before
you start
you should have sound tactics in place
before you start
banking on your psychological warfare
okay and in my experience
uh when you bank on the psychological
warfare
your probability of victory goes
way down way down okay so
uh like in law enforcement i don't bluff
you you don't block you know but we have
everything in place we're gonna win this
fight
okay so don't know when you say get on
the road
get it on the ground and try to scare
him i can say
get on the ground because everything is
in place
if the fight continues do you see that
so
i'm not trying to distract his mind
okay i am trying to
uh reorganize his entire
body mind his entire being okay
and the way to do that is let's get some
actual displacement some material
displacement going
okay um so my kanata teacher
used to i loved his definition of what
what is it what is it uh
what is kenpo it's when pure
pure knuckle means pure flesh it wasn't
when knuckles make him think where did
you hit me
that that that was his point no
psychological warfare
or better yet you know what the best
is he's thinking about him
flying back there do you get it versus
he's distracted so uh what we're trying
to do
is just use our internal aspects to make
him
no longer be there just like
he's pushing he's no longer there
okay so uh these these won't feel good
uh but i'm not hitting the surface i'm
not hitting the surface
and i'm not even if you pay attention my
fist is not even moving that fast
you see but i'm grounding
i was out here moves it's very relaxed
movement
okay so i'm not pushing him
but as my teacher said i'm not kissing
them either
okay this thing is going to come in
into my energy and i am projecting now
holistically
so so far your grabs is fixated
ballistic
uh fixated projection boom energy is
fixated
this is ballistic same thing
okay that that's what we're trying to do
all right so let's give it a shot of
this
okay that's not what i'm doing and i'm
not giving them
a little tap so in the same way if i was
doing any
nugget with the coffee projection right
i'm sending him out i sending him out in
the exact same way but it's fixated
now now we're gonna do a ballistic okay
so i'm gonna go to
so to hit him that's gonna be the energy
that that thing has to go back into into
my foot
[Music]
so
so he he's not allowed to stand there
buddy your body's got to move that's the
idea okay
back to the throws
right
[Applause]
oh
okay